نبدا اخبار الساعه من السودان وكان انتهاء
الهدنه كان جرس العوده الى المسلسل الدامي
فقد ازدادت حده المعارك في اليومين
الماضيين الاشتباكات دخلت اسبوعها الثامن
ليعلو صوت المدافع والغارات الجويه في
سماء العاصمه الخرطوم شنتها قوات الجيش
بينما ردت عليها قوات الدعم السريع
بالمضادات الارضيه كما اعلن الدعم السريع
اسقاط طائره تابعه للجيش من طراز ميج وذلك
اثر الغارات التي شنها الجيش على مواقع
تابعه لقوات الدعم في منطقه بحري ومن
الخرطوم الى دارفور حيث تجددت الاشتباكات
على وجه التحديد في مدينه كتم ليعلن حاكم
دارفور ميني اركومناوي الاقليم منطقه
منكوبه بعدما شهدتهم النهب وقتل وانتهاكات
فظيعه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات